bonsoir patres
deux derniers de colplay aid for of
dreams une tête pleine de rêves septième
album c'était très attendu ça oui
c'était très attendu et ça arrive
seulement 10 mois 18 mois en fait un an
et demi après le précédent
c'est complet qui va assurer le
spectacle de la mi-temps du super bowl
on a appris ça hier malheureusement ça a
été accueillie avec beaucoup de beaucoup
de sarcasme et je sais pas de repos tant
de de malveillance si je dirais mais en
tout cas le nouvel album sort
aujourd'hui
et est ce que le disque a été précipitée
en tout cas ce qu'on peut dire pas très
sexy c'est que c'est vraiment l'album
c'est la réponse exalté et exaltante ont
très sombre ghost stories le diski
sortie en 2014 et qui était en fait un
album sur le divorce du chanteur et du
parolier prince martin donc je vous
propose d'écouter quelques pièces
choisies de cet album est raide pour le
brise très bien
ah oui
oh
m
à
patrice vous allez remarquer on est
vraiment sur la piste de danse ses
dernières pièces ou plus 8,9 le week-end
c'était avec beyoncé donc championnes de
danse de surcroît je pense pas qu'on
puisse accuser compte les d'opportunisme
c'est à dire que chris martin a toujours
été ne s'est jamais caché en fait de son
amour pour la musique dance pop ne s'est
jamais caché non plus ses ambitions
écrire des chansons pour rihanna justin
est ce que c'est bon parce que beaucoup
de jeux et j'attendais que lubrique
personnel ce qui en fait le problème
c'est qu'ils ont recruté les équipes qui
travaillent avec rihanna et avec kenny
perry et ils se sont perdus en chemin
qu'on peut en fait c'est ça qui était
néanmoins la voix de chris martin je la
trouve incroyablement touchante jeu 5
les sincères mais ça lui va pas du tout
il ya des morceaux qui sont
grandiloquent il ya des morceaux qui
sont très fédérateur qui ont été
vraiment construit pour retentir dans
les stades et des arénas mais un ça
passe plus ou moins bien on n'est pas
sûr par contre il ya vraiment une bonne
fait deux bonnes nouvelles la les deux
bonne nouvelle c'est que dans un an ils
ont essayé quelque chose est de 2 c'est
que plus on les écoute - percée oui le
beau nom mais quand même que ça va être
super bon souple pas ou qui sait alors
on procède se laissait qu'un dernier
extrait jonchaient rebecca puis bien sûr
de vous bon week end à vous oui
quand
gros
ça
m